Thank You Terry that was that was
absolutely amazing it was it was great
to hear you speak like that tonight and
and a real privilege to hear it and
sometimes you know the problem with
politics is you get so you get so
immersed in the business of politics and
the intrigue you sometimes forget what's
important about it and actually even for
me to hear you like that is
inspirational so thank you really it's
funny when I was at University a lot of
them you know and what period versity we
have in their 60s you know 60s right so
it was long time ago obviously yeah and
I was I was actually there in the I was
there in the 70s but it was still pretty
much you know the revolution was was on
fairly constantly unless it was a really
good party that conflicted with it and
you know a lot of guys who used to go
and demonstrations with you know you
bumped into the relator life and they
were sort of merchant bankers and having
been trotskyist before but but but a
horse from him saying to one that I met
years vac that's it used to be so
passionate about the poor and he said no
I'm still passionate he said I'm just
passionate about my bonus and and I said
in where eat do you know did you ever
think back on those times and actually
it was quite interesting when you
started a talk to him he'd lost
something that he wished he hadn't lost
but he just had lost it and therefore
was concentrating on on a purely in a
very much selfish view of the world and
what he had to do and you know when I
I'll try and set this in in a in a
context which is is more discursive
about the issues to do with faith in
globalization but if we just start with
analysis of globalization and
the thing is that if you analyze
globalization it is clear that there are
good and bad aspects to it so when
sometimes people say well are you in
favor of globalization or not I mean
first of all I think it's a curious
question that since I think
globalization is just there it's a force
and it is basically driven by people I
remember it and when I was Prime
Minister having a debate just before I
left office actually which was about we
have and then we have the same do you
have post offices in the in the in the
same sense of little village post
offices where we're at okay here sorry
you know it's like when you said
football you didn't mean socket did you
know you meant not a thing yeah okay I
mean the real football we all know that
it's so here was the problem the problem
was that everyone was really really
attached to their local post office
right the trouble was everyone was
really really beginning to do all the
business through bank accounts and
actually they loved the idea of it but
in fact they weren't using it themselves
so we were having to we couldn't support
the thing financially anymore so we were
having to make closures and so on and
you know I used to have this debate with
people and say they'd say why are you
closing these posts Arthur's knights
actually your closing because you're not
using them anymore and that's just the
way it is so how do we make sense of
that so my point is very very simple
that globalization is a force it's there
and it's driven by people it does have
good and bad effects I mean it can
displace people severely and it can
result in exploitation of people it can
result in communities being reshaped and
changed in ways that those communities
do not want to find uncomfortable at the
same time I think you'd have to say that
the expansion of world trade has
increased overall prosperity and the
fact is globalization also offers up a
lot of opportunities for people
and actually if you go back to Doug's
blobs I can call them that those nations
that were rising up and going off also
to greater prosperity the fact is over
time yeah sure you can make the case in
terms of relative poverty but in
absolute terms as no doubt there's been
major changes and if you look at the the
lifting of people out of poverty in
China in the last 20 30 years which has
been dramatic actually the fact is it
has been dramatic as a result of China
opening up now I know in part of your
reading was about the stiglitz view that
that the China opened up in a very
careful way that's true but actually it
did open up and without the opening up
there's no doubt that wouldn't have been
the economic gain so my point is that we
analyze globalization it is a faucets
there is driven by people this Gooden is
bad in respect of it what is the world
of faith bring to this process of
globalization then and I think
essentially there are three things that
it that it brings to it the first is and
really this is exactly what Tony was
just expressing to us actually
personifying to us it brings to it a
mentality that is about care and
compassion and justice and a belief that
it's both our duty in our obligation to
try to help those less fortunate than
ourselves and so that you know that that
idea and if you go back and read the Old
Testament I mean the prophetic and
challenge to the people the entire time
is a mixture of yes we will return to
the first principles about what our
religion is about but it's also a
prophetic challenge to the people to
remember the poor and to judge our
religious fervor in part in relation to
what we do fought for for the poor so it
brings that mentality but it brings
another aspect to our to the mental
approach to globalization which i think
is very important which most laughs and
I were talking about this morning which
is that it asks the question you know
what is the purpose of life and it
defines the answer in terms of human
flourishing is more than about material
wealth and that is the the from
distinction if you like between having
and being and and what it does in this
aspect is that faith faith hat for
certain not just for the Christian faith
but for all the key face I can think of
the idea of giving as part of the
flourishing of your character in other
words that you're you what you are as a
person is not just about what you have
but what you can give to others that is
absolutely integral to the concept of
faith and therefore the mentality that
faith brings the globalization is a
mentality of concern a commitment action
giving as well as having the second
thing that the faith does is that I
think faith also brings up a dimension
of action now in the in the the
presentation which I again I didn't go
through you can just you can see it one
of the questions we asked in the recent
anti-malaria campaign that was held here
actually about about what the faith
communities could do for the United
Nation development goals from tically
anti-malaria campaign one of the issues
was well the faith community brings an
infrastructure of support and people
premises places of opportunity for
for doing the things that need to be
done in pursuit of those of those goals
so one thing that the faith community
does is that if we're talking about
faith and poverty alleviation the faith
community because of its reach because
of its influence because the fact it's
in so many different places and has has
that vast infrastructure with it clam
play a major part so there's a practical
thing it brings the mentality and it
brings a practical dimension namely the
support mechanisms of the faith
community both in wealthy countries in
order to give and campaign and the
poorer countries in order to distribute
and the help that that's given and I
mean I remember back in two thousand and
two thousand five when we put global
poverty in africa at the heart of the g8
campaign that was really the first time
it had been on the agenda there and the
church has played the normos role in
relation to that and we used to i mean i
was getting more vicars and rabbis and
Imams through the doors of down history
that i was any other type person through
for a time if i remember actually the
one very very busy day and there was I
don't was doing a whole lot of different
things but suddenly they had this this
part of the day that was set aside for
the g8 and the churches and up into
Danny's story came just over a hundred
women Vickers but I actually thought
because I wasn't just my mind wasn't on
the whole thing at all and I suddenly
had to go in and take the meeting and
all the rest of it I thought it was a
joke I thought that went really women
Vickers so I was so sitting around
saying this is fantastic you know and
where did you get the costumes and there
was a messy one of that hey they were in
fact a hundred women vicars and let me
tell you that is a really scary and
quite impressive and it's certainly
extremely intimidating sight better may
I digress so you've got the support
system right which is which is
which is there and the final thing which
I think faith brings to this issue of
globalization is that it brings a strong
sense of values which can then take the
impersonal sometimes random process of
globalization and shape it so that it's
in justices can be remedied and its
opportunities can be more fairly
distributed so what I think is
interesting about globalization as I say
it's a one level it's a process is
driven by people it can have these good
and these bad consequences I think what
the world of faith can bring to
globalization is it can bring an
underlying set of values that mean that
that whilst we as it were understand
that the grain of globalization goes in
a certain way and we're actually in
favor of opening the world up for
example in free trade okay nonetheless
it is our task to make sure that the
consequences of that globalization have
some thought wisdom with a political
philosophy behind them to mitigate the
worst aspects and try and access the
good for a broader range of people and
it also means that those things that in
fact are actually necessary for
successful business and commerce like
trust confidence as sense of the long
term in other words globalization is a
process in my view that will work far
better and more effectively if there is
a strong value system that accompanies
it doesn't have to come from the world
of faith but the world of faith can play
a major part in trying to provide that
that value system so to summarize what
what I think this this issue is is about
is is to recognize
one the mental attitude that the faith
community can bring to globalization
which is a call to justice and to give
as well as to have second it can bring
an infrastructure of support that can
enable us to alleviate poverty in a more
effective way and thirdly in the way
globalization changes our world
economically and socially a strong value
system as necessary and faith
communities can help provide that now
the final thing I think it says this
that and this is a recurrent theme
obviously of all the discussion we have
about about faith and globalization I
think it is easier for faith to play
that role if there is a a view we have a
faith which is open to dialogue and
action with those at different phase
because I think both in the mental
attitude and in the infrastructure and
in the set of values it is easier if
through and not just through our
adherence to our own belief system but
through our respect and willingness to
work with those and coexist with those
of another of a different faith we can
make a greater and bigger more profound
difference which is why i think that the
Interfaith dimension is such an
important part of this